[Musica]
lo dico subito avrei voluto fare la
comica invece che la fisica è sempre
stata la mia passione fin da bambina
quella di voler far ridere appena aprivo
bocca per questo mi sono laureata in
fisica No cosa avete capito perché così
venivo presa seriamente quando facevo le
battute io avevo il mito di Lenny Bruce
e George Carlin e quindi quello volevo
fare e in realtà sto facendo tutt'altro
sono divulgatrice scientifica e racconto
la fisica quantistica la racconto
ovunque e tra l'altro la fisica
quantistica è la cosa più complicata in
assoluto lo diceva anche Nils bor tra i
creatori della fisica quantistica voi lo
sapete la fisica quantistica ha tanti
genitori non uno solo come per la
relatività che il padre uno solo e
Albert Einstein per la fisica
quantistica i genitori sono una ventina
di persone Tra questi c'è Nils Boh e lui
diceva Se pensate di aver capito la
fisica quantistica Allora non avete
capito niente E io proprio quella
racconto nei miei libri e nei miei
programmi TV nei miei spettacoli
teatrali a proposito oggi è il Millesimo
live che faccio in 9 anni neanche Roger
Waters mi
batte la la fisica quantistica è il mio
motivo di vita è questa che racconto e
Forse questa è anche la cosa più comica
della mia vita pensare di spiegarla agli
altri e credere di essere capita Oggi
sono una fisica esistenziale perché usa
i concetti della fisica quantistica per
raccontare il senso della vita quello
che noi viviamo tutti i giorni in
particolare uscirete da questo mio Ted
con un solo concetto di fisica
quantistica nuovo voi dovete sapere che
per entrare nel mondo dell'infinitamente
piccolo che è il mondo che racconto
appunto la M meccanica quantistica Ci
sono delle nuove regole non valgono più
le regole del mondo del reale non vale
più Newton non vale più azione e
reazione non vale più f = m * a valgono
altre regole altre teorie
l'indeterminazione il caso funziona e la
cosa più affascinante è un problema un
problema ancora aperto in fisica
quantistica questo problema si chiama il
problema dell'osservazione Il problema
dell'osservazione è proprio quello di
cui voglio parlarvi oggi Il problema
dell'osservazione è quel problema che
nasce ogni volta che noi guardiamo un
ente quantistico Cos'è un ente
quantistico gli elettroni e i fotoni
sonoo particelle così piccole un milione
di miliardesimo di metro così piccole
che lì Viene sconvolto tutto come vi ho
detto ci sono altre regole altre teorie
Ecco se noi i fisici sono dei voy
passano una vita a guardare nel buco
della la serratura e nessuno li denuncia
perché cercano di capire cosa succede a
quelle grandezze lì soltanto che c'è
questo problema Il problema
dell'osservazione quando noi osserviamo
un oggetto del mondo
quantistico loro si comportano come noi
ci aspettiamo di vederlo fare e quindi
si comportano come noi viviamo nel mondo
del reale perché noi siamo reali Noi
siamo Newton Noi siamo f = m * a Quindi
quando noi li osserviamo diventano
esattamente la cosa che siamo abituati
a vedere Eh ma la cosa incredibile è che
se noi non li osserviamo sono tutt'altro
la materia è anche onda le onde sono
anche materia C'è una strana commistione
una strana confusione lì dentro quello
che Vale non vale più Newton ma vale
l'equazione di Schrodinger l'equazione
più bella secondo me di tutto il mondo
forse la cosa più bella di tutto il
mondo l'equazione di Schrodinger che
dice che dà una probabilità affinché
qualcosa accada una probabilità finché
un oggetto del mondo della fisica
quantistica faccia una certa cosa perché
non si può sapere prima che cosa fa non
si può predire dove va l'elettrone non
si possono applicare le formule che
conosciamo fin da scuola quindi non si
può pensare di spiegare in anticipo che
direzione prenderà l'elettrone si può
avere solo una certa probabilità che
qualcosa accada questa probabilità però
non comprende tutto Non è che quella che
noi siamo abituati a vivere come
normalità 100% c'è anche una piccola
percentuale per cui questo elettrone può
fare delle cose strane tipo Vale Il
l'effetto tunnel quantistico Cioè che se
un elettrone vuole oltrepassare una
montagna lo oltrepassa perché qualcosa
può accadere oppure vale il Principio di
indeterminazione di Heisenberg ma
l'altro personaggio non vi parlo di
Heisenberg oggi di cui voglio parlarvi
oltre a Schrodinger si chiama wolfgan
Pauli Perché lui si faceva esattamente
queste domande wolfgan Pauli è è tra i
creatori della fisica quantistica
esattamente come Schrodinger e come
Heisenberg Pauli era un tipo tosto lui
era Premio Nobel in fisica
1945 è stato lui che ha descritto lo
spin degli elettroni prima nessuno ne
aveva mai parlato Lui ha creato il
principio di esclusione di Pauli ha
creato la simmetria CPT Einstein lo è
definito il suo unico e degno successore
Einstein è anche lui tra i creatori
della fisica quantistica Ecco che Paoli
si faceva queste domande diceva Ma ma
cosa succede Allora se io guardo se se
sono io se sono io un oggetto del mondo
quantistico prendete il gatto di
Schrodinger lui usava un gatto per
cercare di risolvere il problema
dell'osservazione e Paoli diceva Ma se
sono io il gatto il gatto nella scatola
Sono vivo E morto allo stesso tempo
allora Cosa succede se la coscienza è
all'interno dell'oggetto osservato e
quindi il conscio e l'inconscio si
mischiano cosa succede Cosa succede
essere la realtà e la finzione la
finzione è la fisica quantistica si
mescolano c'è una linea di demarcazione
che li tiene separati Ma io voglio
viaggiare proprio su quella linea Lì
queste domande Paoli non se le faceva da
solo nella sua stanza anche perché nella
stanza ci stava ben poco lui era un
grande amante dei bordelli gli piaceva
bere whisky Ma questo è un altro
discorso ad Einstein piacevano molto i
personaggi come Paoli ecco lui lui dice
ma io voglio fare queste domande e
voglio andare a
risolverle andando in analisi da Jung
quindi Pauli e Jung erano amici non lo
pagava perché in cambio Jung voleva che
Pauli gli spiegasse la fisica
quantistica uno scambio equo hanno
iniziato a fare hanno iniziato a
dialogare a parlarsi e così entrambi
volevano arrivare allo stesso fine
volevano arrivare alla stessa alla
stessa creazione di questa grande teoria
che unific passe tutto il mondo del
conscio e dell'inconscio della fisica
del re Ale quindi la fisica classica e
la fisica quantistica Paoli però ci
andava anche per un altro motivo Lui
voleva capire che cos'è l'amore non ha
mai provato amore e le ha tutte pagate
le donne con cui è stato allora andava
da Jung anche per questo voleva capire
che cosa gli mancava realmente nella sua
vita va bene iniziano le loro sedute
d'analisi una volta alla settimana di
mercoledì a bollingen e iniziano a
parlarsi Paoli gli racconta dell'effetto
Paoli Allora i non sono scaramantici
detestano oroscopi queste scemenze Qui
la cosa incredibile è che Paoli e tutta
la comunità scientifica credeva invece
nell'effetto Pauli Cioè lui che era un
fisico teorico quando si avvicinava a un
laboratorio gli oggetti smettevano di
funzionare cioè quando lui arrivava
succedeva sempre qualcosa in laboratorio
per cui dovevano mettere dei cartelli
lui doveva avvisare prima prima che
scendesse dalle parti dei laboratori
figuriamoci una volta a Monaco
ho preso fuoco un macchinario e hanno
subito detto dov'è Paoli mandatelo via
deve essere da qualche parte qui No non
c'era Poi dopo hanno ricostruito di un
viaggio che stava facendo da Zurigo a
Berlino aveva fatto scalo proprio a
Monaco nel momento in cui i macchinari
si sono rotti racconta Tutto questo a
Jung
Jung per la prima volta tira fuori la
parola sincronicità la parola
sincronicità nasce dagli incontri con
Paoli La sincronicità sono due eventi
cas che si verificano nello stesso tempo
Jung dice senza Nessi uno tra l'altro
Jung dice se ci prestate attenzione
allora rivelano qualcos'altro ha
iniziato poi a parlare di dejavu ha
iniziato a parlare sapete no quando
pensi intensamente a una persona e
questa ti chiama oppure la sogni e la
incontri poi il giorno dopo per strada
Jung dice quando state vivendo un
momento di grande grande trasporto
emotivo sia positivo che negativo un
amore grande un amore te vicino a voi
vivrete questi eventi quindi Fateci
attenzione Paoli ci presta attenzione
racconta tutto ad Albert Einstein
Einstein parla di una strana azione
sincronica a distanza e dice voglio
sfidare chiunque a dimostrare che sia
vera Io non forse non ci credo voglio
che qualcuno sperimentalmente lo
dimostri che è vero questa roba qui
arriviamo ai giorni nostri l'ultimo
premio nobel nel 2022 è stato dato
proprio Perché tre fisici hanno
dimostrato che tutto questo ragionamento
è vero È vero È tutto vero e quello che
hanno raccontato loro è una parola molto
semplice la ideata Schrodinger proprio
tra i nomi che vi dicevo prima la ideata
schreder e si chiama entanglement
quantistico l'entanglement quantistico
dice che vale sia per i fotoni sia per
gli elettroni elettroni vuol dire
materia fotoni vuol dire onde gli
elettroni noi siam fatti di elettroni
Ecco l'entanglement quantistico è stato
dimostrato nel dall dal gruppo che ha
vinto il premio nobel nel
2022 Quindi vale per gli elettroni
Quindi vale anche per noi cos'è
l'entanglement
quantistico due
sistemi Anzi prendiamo proprio due
elettroni così usiamo quello che Pauli
ha creato hanno uno spin lo spin degli
elettroni è una caratteristica che
riesci a capire che cos'è soltanto
quando la osservi ve l'ho detto che nel
mondo quantistico succedono cose strane
non intuitive Ecco Supponiamo che siano
due colori lo spin Quando guardiamo un
elettrone vediamo per esempio quello
spin è rosso Oppure può essere blu
possono essere soltanto due Ok mettiamo
questi due elettroni entangled entangled
vuol dire intrecciati li mettiamo sulla
stessa orbita così sono entangled e lì
avviene l'entanglement quantistico vuol
dire che gli spin sono
opposti Supponiamo che per capire lo
Stato di un elettrone ci sia una ruota
Avete presente no La ruota della fortuna
la facciamo girare capiamo Qual è lo
spin di un elettrone perché esce lo
spicchio rosso Facciamo finta che ci
sono solo spicchi Rossi e spicchi blu se
il primo elettrone ha lo spicchio rosso
l'altro immediatamente senza neanche
girare la ruota avrà Lo Spicchio blu
devono essere opposti ora uno degli
elettroni lo allontaniamo lo mandiamo
fuori d' Ancona lo mandiamo fuori
dall'Italia lo mandiamo sulla luna
Facciamo girare la ruota del primo
elettrone questi erano elettroni
entangled e vediamo che l'elettrone ha
lo spin rosso e allora quindi
immediatamente sappiamo che l'altro
elettrone quello sulla luna ha lo spin
blu perché sono entangled questo è
l'entanglement quantistico due sistemi
messi a contatto si scambiano
informazioni e si influenzano a vicenda
e quando vengono messi a distanza
continuano a scambiarsi informazioni a
vicenda Ma questo scusate non è l'amore
è proprio quello che stava cercando
Paoli Paoli Arriverà questo alla fine
della sua vita Dopo un
lungo tortuoso percorso che farà sia con
Jung sia con con tutto il resto della
comunità scientifica non era ben visto
Paoli per quella vita privata che dice
che vi dicevo un po' scapestrata Paoli
sposerà nel frattempo una sua seconda
moglie Franca ma non sarà lei che sarà
l'amore della sua vita er maton un po'
anche solo di facciata si usava spesso
in quegli anni ci sarà invece una fisica
si chiama Cheng shung vu e sarà la prima
fisica che lui stimerà veramente
Figuratevi che con marip Curri neanche
parlava Paoli perché aveva un misto non
riusciva ad essere sullo stesso livello
con altre donne scienziate come lui
fisiche come lui Ecco che questa fisica
a distanza con Paoli è come se si
fossero sempre parlati loro studiano la
stessa cosa senza dirselo mai fino a che
lei dimostra la la violazione della
simmetria CPT proprio la simmetria che
lui stava studiando e così si incontrano
e si accorgono che per una vita hanno
ragionato e hanno parlato sempre con le
stesse parole e proporrà addirittura
Cheng shun vu per la vittoria del premio
Nobel non lo farà soltanto lui lo farà
anche nels bor lo farà anche Albert
Einstein Schrodinger
eisenberg sei dei dei creatori della
fisica quantistica lo proporranno un
anno non lo vincerà secondo anno non lo
vincerà terzo anno non lo vincerà verrà
proposta 19 volte Cheng shun vu non lo
vincerà mai lo stesso problema che lei
ha risolto Era come se
Eh fosse stato commissionato da altri
due fisici questo problema che lei ha
risolto sperimentalmente i due fisici
erano li e young sono stati proposti
loro hanno vinto il premio Nobel Ecco
questo è una delle grandi ingiustizie
che che che regna all'interno del mondo
della fisica storicamente si porta
dietro anche l'accademia reale delle
Scienze di Stoccolma Anche perché 219
premi Nobel assegnati agli uomini e
quattro soltanto alle donne qualcosa di
strano c'è là dentro Ecco quello che sta
succedendo invece a a Paoli va da lei e
gli chiede scusa da parte di tutto il
genere maschile quello che porterà
avanti poi Paoli è ancora un passaggio
successivo sarà la teoria relazionale
della fisica quantistica nata per per
voce ancora di un'altra donna un'altra
scienziata Greta Herman lei dice noi
esistiamo chiunque esista in base alla
relazione con gli altri noi non
esistiamo in maniera oggettiva gli enti
quantistici non esistono in maniera
oggettiva Ma esistono in base alla
relazione che vivono quotidianamente
ogni giorno e che vivono accanto alle
altre persone la teoria relazionale
della fisica quantistica saccheggiata da
tantissimi altri la creatrice è una
donna è Greta
Herman Dunque Paoli è riuscito alla fine
della sua vita quasi involontariamente
nel momento in cui stava Stava cedendo a
aver capito che cos'è finalmente l'amore
Dunque il significato di tutto quello
che vi ho raccontato e quindi e quindi
vi voglio lasciare con le parole di una
poesia indiana una parola di una poesia
indiana figuriamoci l'ultimo viaggio che
ha fatto Paolo è stato proprio in India
ma ma non l'ha letta questa poesia È
strano perché quando uno la sincronicità
la Cerca non la trova mai ecco fa così
questa poesia forse non è neanche una
poesia e forse non è neanche indiana fa
così non mi importa sapere cosa fai per
vivere mi importa Sapere cosa desideri
ardentemente e se osi sognare ciò che il
tuo cuore brama non mi importa sapere
quanti anni hai mi importa Sapere se ti
renderesti ridicolo per amore per i tuoi
sogni per l'avventura di esistere Non mi
importa sapere dove vivi o Quanti soldi
hai mi importa Sapere se riesci ad
alzarti dopo una notte di disperazione e
dolore vissuta fino all'osso sei toccato
il centro della tua sofferenza se i
tradimenti di una vita ti hanno aperto
pure chiuso e accartocciato per paura di
altro dolore non mi importa sapere chi
sei o come sei giunto fino qui mi
importa Sapere se staresti in mezzo al
fuoco con me senza indietreggiare non mi
importa sapere dove cosa o con chi hai
studiato mi importa Sapere se puoi stare
da solo con te stesso e ami la compagnia
che ti tieni nei momenti vuoti non mi
importa Sapere che la storia che mi stai
raccontando sia vera mi importa Sapere
che essere vero sei tu e Sai ballare
pazzamente riempiendoti fino alla punta
del le dita di Estasi senza prevenir per
cautela senza essere realista senza
ricordarti le limitazioni degli esseri
[Musica]
umani